alors benjamin vous avez 18 ans vous
êtes organisateur de soirées je me pose
même pas la question actuellement
puisque vous pratiquez déjà la
désobéissance civile vous continuer à
organiser des soirées de combien de
personnes de 200 personnes à peu près on
va dire ça entre 150 et 200 personnes se
tient nous ce soit non où les gens ici
je dirais pas mais gêne pour s'amuser
profiter parce que les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui sont à dire dans un dans
un moment de souffrance personnelle
même quand ils étudient doivent rentrer
chez eux à 18 heures ils sont enfermés
il voyait pas trop leur famille mermoud
leurs grands parents leur tante leurs
amis ils n'arrivent pas à avancer comme
avant ça devient ils sont dans un moment
de solitude on va dire ils sont tous
seuls face à leur dépression leurs
problèmes au quotidien plus le
confinement plus ces restrictions
ça rajoute de la pression moralement
psychologiquement tout à ces on va dire
c'est une accumulation de beaucoup de
choses et j'ai même moi même des amis à
moi qui ont de très bons résultats et
qui sont dans une dans un petit passage
de dépression on va dire mais c'est
compliqué pour même des amis à moi si on
bat dans des hôpitaux pour se reposer
reprendre leurs études quand ça va se
calmer ils ont fait un break parce que
c'est des conditions un peu trop
strictes pour les jeunes c'est à dire
les gens nous disent vite à houma dire
25 26 ans bon après on va pas mélanger
tout le monde mais on va dire que moi
les cas que je connais les gens qui sont
venus me parler ils ont envie de sortir
pour profiter même s'ils savent qu'ils
prennent des risques ils sont conscients
donc vous ça ne vous pose aucun problème
d'organiser ses soirées
non je dirais pas que c'est un poste
aucun problème c'est que moi je
travaille dans le monde de la nuit de
bages travail en boîte de nuit
donc c'est à dire que nous mêmes tous
les gens qui sont dans le milieu bas de
l'événementiel et de des boîtes de nuit
ils n'ont pas de revenu depuis un
certain temps et donc c'est fermé c'est
encore plus stricte pour les boîtes de
nuit ça veut dire que c'est beaucoup
pratiqué vous n'êtes pas vraiment loin
d'être le seul exemple ah non non je
suis
on va dire qu'il ya très peu de
personnes qui si on prend le risque de
le faire mais moi j'en connais moi moi
même je le fais respecter des règles
sanitaires de base où ils ont flambé de
badens ils boivent avec un masque non
c'est vrai que c'est une question celle
que ce rapport donc on savait encore au
virus est question d'un policier dont la
tombe est très détendue on va dire que
c'est vrai les moyens de vous faire
le problème c'est vrai que niveau ça
restera entre nous militaires des virus
les gens qui prennent l'initiative de
venir de leur plein gré ça veut dire que
moralement et psychologiquement ils
prennent un risque personnel avant
d'être sûr céline responsabilités pour
vous parce que c'est la responsabilité
mais c'est des gens que je connais c'est
des amis proches oui m'enfin c'est un
péché que mais beaucoup d'habitants
n'empêche que vous pensez que on va dire
que je l'aimais que je mets certaines
personnes en danger ou quoi que ce soit
je pense que ça c'est faux l'asie tout
juste une question parce que malek à
part vous est le plus jeune je vais lui
donner la parole benjamin aa par bruno
pomart vous avez eu affaire à la police
à cause de ses histoires de écoutez
houssem sont intervenus ou pas sont
intervenus à temps d'une soirée
il n'a pas peut-être d'organisateurs ou
quoi on est tous tous les gens de la
soirée et moi même on est tous
conscients vous avez tous vers bani a
fait pas tout le monde a été verbalisé
des coffres en personne c'est à dire
qu'ils savent qu'ils vont être verbalisé
qui prennent un risque personnel
ils ont vu que le déplacer je peux vous
comprendre un peu mais dame de tyn ces
conditions n'est plus on est plus à
chaque fois que je noue des années je
suis demain que je voudrais entendre
quelqu'un qui est plus familier des
boîtes de nuit que bruno pomart chez
malek délégué oui il ya des vidéos malek
ne dit pas le contraire c'est qu'il ya
des vidéos
elle cible en vue de consacrer ses dj il
faut dire que tous les autres il ya
beaucoup d'acteurs de la nuit du monde
de l'événementiel qui aujourd'hui ne
bosse pas n'ont pas de revenus cette
année lors des soirées comme ça mais en
descendant d sinon ben moi je mets
dernière soirée sékouba jusqu'à la
fermeture en fin septembre début de mois
je poserai la question totale salue tous
les amis qui nous regardent et j'ai pour
le coup j'ai beaucoup d'années dans dans
le milieu ils ont même pas en plus de
réponse de bercy aujourd'hui il serait
loose face au faso face au minstère et
vous le savez et ils n'ont pas de
réponse la plupart le beau temps est ce
que juste vous pensez pas qu'il ya un
gap entre eux on connaît tous des jeunes
qui aujourd'hui sont dans une détresse
psychologique qui sortent paille ils
sont vissés derrière un écran avec avec
le ils vont pouvoir aller un jour par
semaine
moi je suis bien en cour extérieure des
jeunes qu est ce qu a pas un gars pour
réorganiser un semblant de deux normales
en reprenant une vieille étudiante en
présentiel à petites doses et faire une
soirée de deux cents personnes
parce que j'entends j'entends ils
viennent de leurs preuves de leur plein
gré la responsabilité c'est pas
forcément la mienne mais je suis désolé
je suis pas là pour faire culpabiliser
les gens même si la personne ne la
laissait à personne elle symptomatique
et tout va bien pour elle c'est très
bien je crois que c'est le transmet à
ses parents après 34 ans max et toujours
les cas les pierres dans ce genre de
produit on voit le pire que le pire dans
la vie mais parce que là il ya un
variant et finir l'océan marion plus
transmissible la parole donc de fait la
question autant de la réponse de
benjamin ensuite jeunes veulent
intervenir un super méchant il faut
prendre un coup
benjamin la parole ouais on met pas tout
mélanger dans la vie les virus les
problèmes psychologiques
les problèmes de famille les problèmes
de travail les problèmes d'argent si ce
soit d'autre aujourd'hui changement sur
ce plateau
il ya des gens quand même du
gouvernement tout quand même moi qui est
plus jeune que à peu près vous tous ici
de l'extérieur c'est c'est pas que j'en
faisais que ça fasse ça fait peur mais
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas de moment de
parole on dirait c'est un combat de coqs
je veux avoir raison c'est moi qui a
raison dans la chaumière non je n'en
serais pas là question qu'on vous a posé
on vous dit que il ya une responsabilité
parce que les gens qui participent à
votre soirée peuvent transmettre le
virus et éventuellement le transmettre à
des personnes fragiles avec donc des
conséquences graves voilà la question
mélange pas tout et ils ont un test ils
vont en pharmacie tout est bien tout ça
avec un test négatif 0 y ait un test je
vois ton contrôle tout on voit tout mais
pas n'importe où n'importe qui n'importe
quand n'importe quel argent
je fais un appel juste à tous les
organisateurs de soirées parce qu'à la
reprise il faudra l'embauché oui parce
que faire une telle organique un test
négatif à l'entrée
c'est en petit comité attention vous le
disais pour moi 50 cents personnes
celles équivaut dans un appartement
c'est comme un dîner avec du monde
hawaï a débriefé on ya passé devait seul
chez moi il ya un emplacement
il ya des lieux c'est un moment festif
où les gens prennent du plaisir mon
personnel pour leur plein gré et leur
vie sociale à eux n'en parle des
conséquences
voilà la conséquence oui et que je
comprends mieux qu'ils s'amusent en
soirée qu'ils sont qui sort de boîte
alcoolisés ils prennent les conséquences
qui viennent s'alcooliser se met en
danger tous les jours aux biens ils
confondent est conscient de ça quand
même